quand on regarde aussi le rapport gauche
droite eh bien on se dit que on peut
envisager le deuxième tour avec
confiance en appelant nos concitoyens à
se mobiliser pour que la gauche qui a
très bien géré cette région qui a un
remarquable une remarquable tête de
liste et bien continue à travailler pour
le bien commun et pour tout les normands
les normands savent que leur région
était bien géré les normands savent
qu'on a fait une politique de la
jeunesse qui a apporté une aide pour
tous les adolescents qui fréquentent les
lycées la carte livre la carte a'tout
ici des choses comparables en haute
normandie
ils savent qu'on a modernisé les trains
d'équilibré du territoire les ter qui
sont tous ceux qui ont tous été
remplacés qui sont habiles savent qu'on
naît des entreprises à flers les gens
savent que la région a sauvé faurecia
donc tout ça a dû peser aussi tant qu il
faut faire un choix entre ses
orientations nationales mais aussi ses
intérêts chevaux